[Musique]
si depuis le début du confinement
imposée par le gouvernement la grande
majorité des français à respecter les
consignes on a pu observer un peu
partout sur le territoire des citoyens
moins disciplinés que d'autres sorties
de confort faux footing excuse bidon
pour certains sortir semble plus
important que lutter contre la
propagation du virus
et si ces comportements peuvent agacer
ils ont développé chez certains une
réponse tout aussi dérangeantes la
délation d'après la police ces derniers
jours les appels au 17 concerne dans 70%
des cas des dénonciations de voisins
pour non respect du confinement selon le
responsable adjoint du syndicat
alternatif police si certains de ces
appels peuvent être utiles dans la
grande majorité des cas et sont
excessifs dire que la personne a sorti
quatre ou cinq fois son chien que la
personne s'est rendue à plusieurs
reprises dans un magasin pour faire ses
courses ou dénoncer des jeunes enfants
qui sont en train de s'adonner à des
pratiques sportives
c'est effectivement un petit peu
excessif une pratique qui est de retour
et qui pour beaucoup rappellent de
mauvais souvenirs pourtant ce qu'ils
appellent explique que c'est pour la
santé de tous qu'ils le font à leur
augmentation des délations choquer ou
pas choquer alors pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent c'est le gros débat du jour
donc choqué ou pas choquer augmentation
des délations je vous donner quelques
chiffres dans le grand est par exemple
le syndicat alternatif le syndicat de
police alternat 10 indique que 50% voire
70% des appels reçus par la police sont
des appels de délation précisant que sur
500 appels par jour à strasbourg
plus de la moitié dénonce des personnes
et sur 27 appels en une heure à nancy 22
d'entre eux concernent le non respect
des règles de confinement voilà d'où
l'idée donc c'est entre 50 et 70% aussi
dans la région nouvelle aquitaine voilà
est par exemple il n'y a quasiment pas
d'appel de délation dans le poitou
charentes
voilà un mot par région c'est vrai que
ça change énormément on va faire un
petit tour d'abord de nos éditorialistes
est ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas et
après j'aimerais qu'on entende bien sûr
je denis jacob secrétaire général
d'alternative police qui est avec nous
et qui lui a enfin exprimé un petit peu
son ras-le-bol d'avoir des appels pour
dénoncer et rodolphe thomas maire
d'hérouville saint clair dans le
calvados qui lui appelle à dénoncer
c'est une commune de 22 mille habitants
dans le calvados voilà alors vous est ce
que vous comprenez est ce que vous êtes
choqués par l'augmentation de la
délation c'est un truc vraiment dont
tout le monde parle aujourd'hui raymond
moi je suis choquée parce que j'ai pas
été moi je paie télécom ça rappelle des
mauvais souvenirs de pharma délassant
pis c'est facile de faire de la délation
avec quelqu'un qui se défend pas t'aider
à internet tu fait de la délation
t'appelle avec un mec mais il ya plein
d'exemples où toute l'année tu peux
faire de la délation et personne ne
bouge une oreille quand tu vois
quelqu'un qui est sur un trottoir avec
son scooter tu peux faire de la délation
mais tu ne sais pas quand tu vois le mec
qui en trente s'embrouille avec sa nana
tu peux aller aller faire de la délation
tu le sais pas la donation pour moi pour
moi c'est mon avis c'est quand je sais
que ton voisin étape sa femme quand tu
sais qui tape ses enfants quand tu sais
qu'il ya des histoires de viols
maltraitance là tu peux faire de la
délation et dira voilà où aller voir toi
même et dire arrête tes conneries mais
la délation c'est facile à faire quand
est caché derrière un téléphone ne sais
quoi mais il ya demain on voit plein
d'image où il a plein de fois tu peux
faire des délations mais si tu sais que
le mec qui va venir te mettre une tarte
dans la gueule tu vas faire de la
délation de rien du tout donc je pense
que c'est un faux pas très beau très bon
résumé de raymond très beau résumé très
bon immature de leurs maux matthieu
delormeau
c'est au nord quand j'écoute raymond
parce que parce que dénoncer son voisin
quitte sa femme c'est bien mais en
revanche dénoncer quelqu'un qui va
sortir et prendre le risque d'avoir des
personnes qui peuvent avant le corona
virus et en mourir ou bien mourir des
gens de sa famille ça en revanche c'est
choquant moi je ne suis pas choqué et
comme justement l'autre jour j'ai dit
que ce ne fut qu'un peut insulter sur
twitter j'ai été à garder et je veux
vraiment vu que raphaël enthoven pardon
c'est un philosophe c'est pas un débile
a bien expliqué qu est ce qu on appelle
la bonne délation celle qui se moque des
gens et la mauvaise délation par exemple
pendant la guerre et arrêtez de penser
que les françaises sont débiles et
qu'ils appellent à la différence qu'ils
savent faire la différence et arrêter de
penser que parce qu'on va dénoncer pour
la corée navires us derrière ensuite
année prochaine
on dénoncera pour l'urssaf ou pour
autour des immigrés compas de papier
c'est pas vrai les gens sont
intelligents et justement pour m avant
de finir si la délation peut empêcher un
jour justement que quelqu'un dans ta
famille et cette maladie et héééé mais
un problème tu seras bien content que
quelqu'un l'ait fait en solo mais là
j'en pense aux autres mathieu je pense
aux débits moi mais je vais prendre moi
je sais que je suis un peu perturbé
quand même parce que qu'on ait besoin de
la police pour faire respecter des
règles de bon sens j'ai du mal à
comprendre que les joggeurs ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles ne comprennent
pas l'urgence actuellement et je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on puisse mettre un policier
derrière chaque sou de citoyens qui ne
respectent pas les règles je pense que
les policiers ont peut être autre chose
à faire je pense que les images qu'on
voit tous les jours on parle tous les
jours du soignant tout
vous avez des infirmières des médecins
que explique la situation à laquelle on
est si ça ne suffit pas je ne suis pas
sûr qu'une amende d'un policier
suffisent et puis bien sûr pas oublier
que jusqu'où on va aller je discutais
avec une patiente qui me disait je ne
comprends pas j'ai vu une dame dans la
rue tranquille avec une poussette et un
enfant mais je d'écouter cette dame là
peut-être c'est une famille
monoparentale
peut-être qu'elle n'a pas le choix que
de sortir avec sa fille pour aller faire
les courses
on ne sait pas ce que font les gens bord
servi le voyez dehors évidemment je ne
parle pas du maître qui fait un barbecue
tranquille avec ses voisins ça peut vous
juste serré je comprends mais je ne suis
pas sûr que la réponse policière soit la
seule nécessaire même si je comprends
mathieu c'est pour sauver des vies on a
l'impression qu'il ya un intérêt
supérieur à faire de la délation
malgré tout chaud ça dérangeant je pense
que les policiers ont quelque chose à
faire que de répondre à tous ses appels
alors voilà on devrait maintenant besoin
d'aidé on devrait être juste et
responsable on sort le minimum on
devrait pas avoir besoin de bouts de
papier on nous a arraché la future liste
parce que finalement on ne respecte pas
les règles il faut juste rester c'est
dans le monde des bisounours à jimmy
tout le monde des priorités malvy mon
opinion de la berner encore qu'elle va
parler je cherche seulement contre la
délateur à moins que la jeune officier
le politique qui va venir
denis jacobine et là il est déjà là oui
il est déjà là alors je lui poserai la
question est que le policier y va est-ce
que 6 devant deux policiers le politique
peut lui dire oui c'est lui qui a fait
des folies
ah bon alors ça on va on va en parler
dans un instant justement puisqu'on à
denis jacob secrétaire général
d'alternative police merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes donc le secrétaire
général du syndicat alternatif police
qui a lancé l'alerté sur ce phénomène
vous en avez ras le bol des délations et
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi parce qu'après on va donner la
parole à rodolphe thomas qui lui est un
maire dont qui a appelé à la délation de
nice pourquoi vous en avez marre d'avoir
des appels de délation tout le monde en
a parlé aujourd'hui d'affaires serré les
merci pour votre hésitation
plusieurs choses parce que je voudrais
déjà réagir à ce qui a été dit 1
il n'est pas interdit de sortir il ya
des attestations qui permettent de le
faire
et deuxièmement la maladie il faut
savoir mais il ya un médecin qui est en
ligne
également il pourra peut-être confirmé
mais qu'une grande partie de la
population porter d'u
russe de manière symptomatique donc il
est compliqué de déterminer à l'instant
t quand on va contrôler une personne de
savoir s'ils allaient porter ou non du
virus et donc pour nous c'est compliqué
de travailler dans ces conditions alors
la délation
si le mot est approprié parce
qu'effectivement ça rappelle des heures
sombres là et bien sûr ans que le
contexte est pas tout à fait le même
qu'il faut pas tout mélanger
ceci étant quand on est appelé par une
personne sur ce qu'on appelle le dit
certes c'est à dire le numéro d'appel le
policier rien à l'urgence nous sommes
tenus quelle que soit le motif
d'intervenir alors qu'on ne peut pas
refuser d'aller sur une intervention une
personne nous appellent parce qu'elle a
vu quelqu'un sortir et qu'elle ne serait
pas la légitimité de le faire et bien
nous sommes obligés de nous déplacer ce
qui peut dire que la personne que l'on
voit dans la rue n'est pas porteur
légitime de l'attestation pour sortir
donc c'est très compliqué à gérer
et d'ailleurs le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a rappelé pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui
lors de son audition au sénat l'étape de
la verbalisation est un échec
nous avons près de 13 millions de
contrôles sur les 13 millions de
contrôles moins de 800 milles
verbalisation donc ça témoigne bien que
de toute façon la répression à cocktail
ne sert pas et qu'il faut faire passer
deux messages le premier appelé au
civisme de la population parce que c'est
la base de tout pour endiguer la
propagation du virus et de dire que
quand on nous appelle pour des futilités
de personnes que l'on voit dans la rue
alors qu'elle est porteur peut-être
d'une attestation et bien c'est robert
sa aubert le bon fonctionnement des
services de police parce que quand on
intervient sur ce type d'intervention
sur ce petit de missions fremm l'année
revenir sur d'autres plus importantes
mais on intervient pas sur des missions
plus graves et potentiellement des
personnes en danger notamment
ça fait partie du confinement mais
l'augmentation exponentielle des
violences conjugales exactement denis
alors on à rodolphe thomas qui est avec
no mercy rodolphe thomas d'être là vous
êtes maire de hérouville saint clair
dans le calvados
et vous
regardez vous avez appelé e
voilà vous avez fait appel à vos à vos
habitants à ne pas hésiter à appeler la
police lorsqu'ils voient une
invincibilité devant leurs yeux regarder
si vous avez bon jour à tout
bonjour à tous je sais que les règles de
confinement qui s'adressent à nous
aujourd'hui ne sont pas respectées par
tous les directives du gouvernement sont
claires pour préserver nos familles nos
amis et nos voisins
il est obligatoire que nous restions
confient les chez nous désormais toute
infraction est passible d'une amende de
135 euros et la police nationale tout
comme la police municipale ferons
appliquer toutes les mesures en
direction de ceux qui ne respecteront
pas les consignes telles que
l'interdiction des regroupements sur
l'espace public pour tout signalement
n'hésitez pas à contacter la police
nationale au 17
voilà alors merci d'être avec nous
rodolphe thomas maire d'hirson calvados
merci alors monsieur le maire de jute
vous avez fait cet appel dont pourront
dit voilà où il est fait un appel à
dénoncer voilà ceux qui commettent des
incivilités
c'est pas à l'énoncé série le savent
alors soit socialement je ne vais pas
dénoncer délation c'est pas en appelant
en demandant aux français d'appeler le
17 on est sûr de la délation enfin moi
ça fait 20 ans que je suis maire
d'hérouxville à aucun moment j'ai amené
à appeler à chaque fois le 17 on est là
sur véritablement de la prévention et de
la sensibilisation auprès de l'ensemble
de celles et ceux qui ne respectent pas
effectivement les règles de confinement
donc c'est parti sur sincèrement sera un
bon sentiment de la appelé de
l'appellation
j'en veux dire excusez moi les bras m'en
tombent et tout ça c'est venu la vidéo
vous avez fait passer à l'instant elle
est en fait allé presque plus de dix
jours après la situation parce que
beaucoup de gens se plaignaient qui est
effectivement respectées le confinement
et le voyons beaucoup de
personne sortir surtout au pied des
immeubles moi j'étais plus axé sur des
cartes ou et effectivement il ya des
grosses difficultés de squat de
différentes délinquance au pied des
immeubles
et ce sont les habitants qui on veut
dire nous on est confiné et vous laisser
certains types d'un certain sens surtout
ne se reparler d'eux des fabriques vous
avez cité tout à l'heure dans gauche moi
j'essaye encore le maire d'assumer cette
responsabilité plus dans le cadre de la
sensibilisation et de la prévention
mais pour apporter dans certains moments
certains quartiers un peu de respect du
cadre de vie
sur l'ensemble comment dirais-je des
pieds d'immeubles où c'est mon rôle en
tant que maire mais j'ai surtout pas
voulu froisser
enfin la ligue des gros oeuvre à aucun
moment ça me faisait lignée de parler de
délation
enfin je lâche m'en remets à la alors à
bien par des dessins à part vous
monsieur le maire c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
on l'est on l'a vu avec denis jacob
il reçoit ils reçoivent énormément
d'appels de plus en plus d'appels son
vrai nom ciation voilà mais ce n'est pas
ne s'est pas de voter bien entendu mais
c'est vrai que c'est un phénomène qui
est en train vraiment de pulluler soit
c'est de plus en plus jean-michel toi
qu'est ce t'en penses tu l'as bien là
bas moi je trouve ça évidemment choquant
et j'étais content a de la bonne foi de
monsieur le maire mais quand il ya des
signalements où la délation c'est pas
pour faire de la prévention on n'appelle
pas les policiers pour qu'ils viennent
dire à son voisin attention faites
attention c'est pour le sanctionner et
que la délation malheureusement c'est
toujours un acte malveillant on dénonce
pas ses potes dans l'immeuble mais
dénonce celui qui se garent à sa place
de parking qui gicle fait chier parce
que si on doit avoir et on se venge en
ne signalant pas ce qu'ils sortent sans
raison apparente sait jamais un acte
bien payé enfin alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait ce qu'ils vont tirer du chocolat
les chalets giro je reprends mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait dans ce cas là on met plus
la série d'auditions les violences
faites aux femmes sur les violences
intrafamiliales un moment donné
heureusement qu'il y ait des
signalements ont justement que la police
nationale ou bien encore en ce qui
concerne la police mentionne puisse
intervenir mais on le fait quand tout ça
pour rendre service et de respecter donc
de faire respecter comme die les droits
et les devoirs désolé d origine
dans certains quartiers à aller au pied
des immeubles à un moment donné
les français en ont ras-le-bol opposé
michel r seulement rien à perdre et
daniel jacobs s'il vous plaît oui
d'accord il faut quand même relativiser
cette situation elle est bien sûr inégal
à travers le territoire national car
elle est très localisée sur certaines
grandes métropoles comme bordeaux
toulouse lens strasbourg ou même nancy
et puis il faut pas confondre le fait
d'appeler la police parce que on veut se
venger d'un voisin avec qui on a eu des
prêts et qu'ils se retrouvent dans la
rue n'a guère fait appeler la police
secours au 17
parce qu'on est témoin de faits graves
de violence conjugale d'un voisin ou de
délinquance ou de crime bien évidemment
c'est pas de la dénonciation c'est de
l'assistance à personne à danger engorgé
exactement exact denis jacob petite
question comme ça parce qu'on a parlé
tout à l'heure
est ce que c'est vrai qu'à une
recrudescence des agressions dans la rue
ou pas du tout et des cambriolages ou
pas du tout c'est une idée reçue
non j'ai pas d'information qui
abonderait en ce sens et là aussi il
faut qu'on puisse accomplir nos missions
de manière normale quand on est
monopolisée sur des dénonciations
intempestives on peut pas se consacrer à
la lutte contre la délinquance
il a cumulé on ne peut pas dire en tous
les cas sur l'ensemble du territoire
ciat je ne dis pas qu'il n'y en a pas
ici ou là mais en tous les cas au niveau
national à ma connaissance je suis pas
au ministère de l'intérieur il faudrait
poser la question d'un carton mais un
mccalman pas une recrudescence de
cambriolages ou de vol prenez un truc
oui je voulais poser la question au
maire à la barre comme est une ville de
combien d'habitants où 32 min l'horizon
ni la vingtaine il habite en vous parlez
à quelqu'un sait où des pieds le maire
d'une grande ville comme marseille qui
est un peu parti être à mazamet l'abri
marseille comme par hasard est-ce que
vous ayez pris cette décision parce que
la soupe rédigé le maire de marseille a
prêté des studios c'est la guerre civile
parce que tout se sait martèle village
et croyez moi que vous aurez du mal à
faire passer ça ou gérer pour moi je
veux juste qu'ils m'expliquent alors
attendez pas laisser leur répondre
non mais je comprends bien sincèrement
pour une ville de 20 premiers habitants
quand les rosiers de sinclair je répète
on est toujours parti sur des bons
sentiments et ne surtout pas je le
répète de la délation
donc effectivement comparer et huila à
marseille ou en banlieue parisienne
bien sûr que c'est difficile mais quand
vous avez aussi des retours je me répète
des habitants et quand on essaye un pont
soit que de faire respecter les règles
de confinement il faut qu'on essaye de
sensibiliser et trouver injuste curseur
un juste milieu et surtout pas jean prix
de parler de délation quoi on nettoie ce
responsable
alors je regardais g mais je vais pour
aider je vais vous montrer
je voudrais je vous montre une vidéo qui
va vous et qui va vous faire marrer va
pas vous faire marrer qui va va vous
faire froid dans le dos regardez il y en
a qui sont en avance sur nous là dessus
j'ai pas très envie qu'on atteigne leur
niveau je me dis tout de suite ces
décotes j'ai la délation et l'école de
la délation en corée du sud
en gros c'est simple plus le dénonce
plus reçoivent d'argent regardez c'est
juste ça regarde dans cette école pour
adultes de séoul
on apprend ni l'informatique ni les
langues étrangères mais la délation
ici on enseigne les trucs et astuces qui
permet de dénoncer ses compatriotes
auprès des autorités
le directeur on y voit rien de choquant
tim torlot colombo d'un côté et à ceux
qui respectent la loi et qui n'ont rien
fait de mal
cela prouve le système de compensation
par contre ce qu'ils ont peur d'être
dénoncé s'en plaignent cela fait des
années que le gouvernement coréen offre
d'importantes récompenses aux délateurs
mais le phénomène a pris de l'ampleur
sous le mandat de l'actuel président
conservateur
l'après midi les élèves ont droit à une
séance de travaux pratiques
c'est le moment de sortir les caméras
cachées
la caméra est à l'intérieur de cette
pochette et le bouton que vous voyez
sert à cacher l'objectif les écoles de
la délation coréenne font déjà des
émules
la chine a créé une école similaires et
d'autres pays seraient intéressés allez
on va voir le sondage regarder on vous a
posé la question
augmentation des délations choqué à 62%
à choquer à 38%
je voulais remercier rodolphe thomas
d'avoir est avec nous et denis jacob
également celle ci d'avoir été là merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation